yeah
hi everyone I'm javadi from UTS team
now I will introduce our work at itcs
2023 consensus division in an arbitrary
ratio
this is a joint work with Paul Goldberg
let's start with a classical problem
called lucky splitting
it's now Suppose there are two thieves A
and B and they still a necklace so
suppose this necklace is a string it's
an open necklace
and on that necklace there are any type
of bees and the ice type this has a
iPhone
because we have two Zips so now we just
suppose AI is even number for all I
so this example this is a string of this
in total eight and there are three types
of them
so now our goal is to split this
necklace we want to cut this necklace in
some places
and give some pieces to the safe a and
some pieces to still be such that it's
either split even split means each step
gets same number of bees of each type
so here is example so we cut the
necklace in three places
and we give the first and the third
piece to the a second and
fourth piece is 250 B and you could
check that
Steve a get two blue bees one green
beast and one yellow piece CP also gets
two blue beads one green beast and one
yellow piece okay so it's a even split
and Yuri we want the cut the number of
cut to be as few as possible because
maybe okay the strings on that necklace
is also valuable
so by a topology theorem called first
balloon theorem you can show that uncut
always suffice
however
to find a solution with only a cause is
competitionally hard
and a classical result show that it's PV
complete
so we will introduce what is PPA this
class later
so now uh imagine scenario one of the
Steve said I should get two-thirds of
each type of piece because I did the
most dangerous job
that's a quite natural scenario right
so in our paper we started a natural
transition of the classical
accessibility problem we call it alpha
imbalanced necessibility alpha is a
ratio between 0 and 1.
so the problem definition is mostly the
same
the only difference is that now we want
to cut a thick necklace and
distributes a pieces between CV and CB
such as if a gets Alpha
times a i of these of tab I
still the original Network expressing
problem is a special case with Alpha
equal to 0.5
so in this model we may have some
questions so how many costs are needed
especially in the worst case
okay in this problem so our uncut still
enough right
and now with the computational
complexity of this problem
is this problem still PPP complete or
belongs to some different costs does it
get easier or more difficult
a very closely related model called
Kansas Harvey so causative is a
continuous generalization of necklace
rating
so uh
instead of having type of bees now it's
a continuous problem so we have a
probability mirror function
on the
unit integral 0 1.
and we want to okay we want to divide
this interval zero one into two sets of
intervals
sucks that
the mirror
for each mirror function the set a
contains about roughly half of the
matter
so because it's a continuous problem
usually okay to define a computational
problems it's continuous so we need some
aerator or approximation error so when
absolute is inverse polynomial you can
show that causes hobby problem is
equivalent to negative speed you could
build reduction in both ways
and the class having is also shown to be
PVA complete
and it's pretty complete even for
constant approximation still note that
the larger the approximation error is
the easier the problem gets so it's
even keeping complete for constant
approximation which is a very recent
results
so naturally we could also Define a
imbalanced version of the constant
halving problem we call it Alpha
imbalanced consists division
so we also have a ratio Alpha between
zero and one and the problem is same as
constant halvings the only difference is
that now we require okay one set of
intervals a contains Alpha which
approximately Alpha plus or minus
absolute
fraction of the matter for each memory
function
and interestingly this model has been
studied in a very old paper by a
stromaquest and Udo
so this show that
a general upper bound of 2nd so it means
two and because it's always enough for
any ratio Alpha
and they also construct examples showing
that for any irrational ratio Alpha
in the worst case two um costs are
needed
so in this talk and actually our paper
we focus on the imbalance constitivity
model not the negative spacing mode but
we already tell you it's equivalent
actually so all the results about
rational ratio Alpha in the chances
division could be applied to the
imbalance negative splitting problem
yeah in the next three problem you
cannot Define a irrational ratio Alpha
so before we introduce our results
um to give more background of the
complexity side
about complex class tfmp PVA and PPK
so tfmp
is a cast content or total NP search
problem so third form means you want to
find a solution not only decide this yes
or no
and total means a solution always exists
and NP means you could verify whether a
solution is a valid solution important
number time
so kfmp has many important subclasses
and has been a very Hot Topic in the
five years
in the subclass that is most relevant to
our work is PVA PPA is for the parity
argument
so consider giving you a graph
and in that graph there is a vertex of
odd degree
then there must be another vertex of our
degree so this is a third argument so
the computational problem
of PK is take two
give you a start vertex with our degree
you should find the other one
foreign
ization of PPA
so to summarize is okay give you a Bible
type graph and I give you a start vertex
V this the degree of a mod K is not zero
then there must be another vertex V this
degree mode K not equal to zero so it's
kind of a mode K argument
so basically by definition PPA is pk2
and another uh property I want to you
know is that
it's believed that for two different
Prime P1 and P2 PPA P1 and pvp2 are not
comparable means for example pp2 doesn't
content pv3 and pv3 also doesn't contain
TV2
and unlike PPA has some natural Complete
product like like splitting
to get K now
we have very few natural complete
problems
yeah another related problem is called
consistent division
so authentic division is generalized
conserving in a different way so our
imbalanced consensus division is okay
now we still have two Thief but we don't
want a one-half one half split we want
to split two alpha and one must Alpha
but in the classical division now we
have tested
and we want to divide into a k part and
each part have y over k
and in this case you could show that
in the worst case n minus 1 times n
class is enough
yeah this problem has been studied
before
it has been shown that this problem is
in PPK by through reduction
and in particular if K is a power of
prime okay k equal to P to R for Prime P
then this problem is in PvP which is is
which relies on the property of the
previous key class
and this problem is conjectured to be
pvk complete for product k
so this is a major open problem in this
field
and you could similarly Define K
negative splitting
so now we are ready to introduce our
results so first from the combinatoric
side we show how many cards you need to
guarantee a solution the first is a
lower Bond
so that any rational ratio Alpha okay
with the same Alpha equal to l over k
then roughly 2 times K minus 1 over K
times n class are needed in the first
case
so to be more clear here is a
visualization so here I plot the lower
Bound for all rationals number with
denominator smaller than 50 and they
form a quite beautiful pattern
so for example this dot okay Alpha equal
to 1 over 2 is a classical
as a hobby or Nexus basic problem and in
this case Okay the bound is M okay these
are previous results
and for any other Alpha
we show that there is a bound between L
and 2N
d
and actually this pattern is identical
to an upside down filmus function
and we call that the stromacast and the
Widow show that for any irrational Alpha
the bound is 2N so above
or the rest of them
and this third one is put by a pure ad
hoc Construction
to also give some upper balance
so the first part around showing that
for a large subset of rational numbers
we have the same upper bound
so we should show that for last subset
to start for any Alpha in Q star we get
match matching lower bound and upper
Bond
and it's difficult to give an explicit
form about Q star or short description
but I can tell you Q star contains all
the fractions of form one over K and it
also contains a lot more
fractions
and for any other rational Alpha we give
our upper bounds of C Alpha times n
where C Alpha is constant strictly
smaller than two okay so we still
improve upon previous upper bounds of 2N
so what in numerical example is that for
like Alpha equal to two over five our
upbound is nine over five times n while
the lower box is eight over five times n
so this upper bound is from a reduction
from the consensus K division so for
example to get upper Bound for one over
three in Balance Constitution
we use a reduction from consists of
three division
so this type of reduction is inspired by
also by the original strongest and budok
paper
and we believe the lower bound seems to
be tight and the upper bone is not
optimal so it's not only the passage of
lauravone it looks prettier if you read
the proof upper bound it feels a kind of
weak
especially for this for the number not
in Q star this looks stuffable
so now
we introduce our result about complexity
part
so first for the same subset Q star of
rationalism
Alpha so we show that finding the
solutions okay using this number cut so
this number is both the lower volume and
upper bound
so this comes their problem lies in pvk
under true induction
and in particular if K is a power of 5
okay then this follow lies in PvP for
the prime p
so for example solving one-third in
Balance consists division is four over
three times uncut lies in pp3
so this term three is basically from the
same reduction to get upper bound it
will use similar from the complicated
vision
and we also get
a kind of intriguing complex results
when you give more Cuts than necessary
so usually when we started next
splitting because hobby we consider okay
what's the minimum number of costs that
makes this problem total but it's
natural that if you give more Cuts then
the problem maybe becomes easier
and here is a result
so for any Alpha then l a prime P we
show that finding an inverse polynomial
approximate solution using okay this is
a
this is still a constant times uncut is
in PvP this is a constant only
related to l
so here are some examples so for uh any
Alpha let me show that the alpha in
Balance consecutive Vision with two
uncuts using PPA
okay and for the constant having a
problem where Alpha is equals 0.5 okay
if you give eight uncuts then this
problem is in pv3 now
so previously I felt it's believed that
PPA and PPE is pk2 PPA is not comparable
with pp3 so if with ETA and class this
problem is not only PPA now it's also in
pbs3 so it's a strong evidence this
problem with it and cause becomes
strictly easier
and two so this kind of results uh we
also have some this kind of result
previously so uh
people have shown that for customers
having it's still people complete with n
plus n to the Y minus Delta cost so
Delta is any constant
yeah but this is still smaller than like
zero 1.001 is right
so it doesn't give like linearly more
cuts
and on the upper algorithm side
people have shown that if you give
a log and cuff
then finding an inverse polynomial
approximations solution is in p
but here is a visualization of the
situation for solving conserving with
inverse polynomial approximation
okay so if you only give a month one
card so this problem is not even total
of the solution with L minus one because
not always exists this problem is empty
complete
and once you give Uncle this problem is
become in PPA and accurate for uncut or
even n plus n to the 0.99 cuts this
problem is still PPP complete
okay and our people show that okay once
you give a 10 cards then this problem
further belongs to ppa3
and you could also plug five into this
Bond and you will get with 12 uncuts
this proper further
becomes in pp5
and if you give too much cut like unlock
uncut then this problem is in p
so we believe this bound is not
optimal but it does give you a sense
that what happened when you get more
cuts
and according is okay for any Prime P if
you want to find a vertical consummation
solution for the concentrate division
problem okay then you still need
about uh a constant times and cuts that
is EPP okay this bond is now related to
KMP but still a constant
and note that this bond is
basically three minus one multiply the
previous Bond and actually this query is
proved by okay to solve a constantly
division
you could solve it by coding the
imbalance consist division T minus one
times okay
you start by calling out 1 over K and
that's considered division so now you
top out one part of one okay of shear
and then you apply the one over K minus
one invest consideration on the okay on
the revenue part okay then you again cut
out one over K share of in the original
instance and you do this three months
one times
and our last result is shown that
so for any Alpha find a solution using
the minimum number of class for each
specific instance SMP hard
because now this problem is not a tfmp
problem because
for each specific instance okay we want
to find a solution it's the minimum
number class
so this is reduced from the exactly ones
to set problems so exactly once reset
means okay you want to get this
assignment such that exactly one
letter is satisfied in each class
and this is similar to the this
construction this reduction is similar
to the construction of the lower bound
and this result is not very surprising
because in the previous people people
already show that decide whether a const
heavy
from an instance could be solved with n
minus one because it's NPR
so our result is a transition of
previous results
yeah but I still want to say our proof
is very different
so in the previous paper the the
reduction is from the stat problem and
a mentor in the reduction is to use a
problem called generalized circuit
problem J circuit so this circuit is a
two problem constructed usually for
reduction in PPD but our reduction
doesn't use these three circuit it's
completely different
finally we will introduce some other
problems left in this paper
so the first one is to close the gap
between our current floor bone and upper
belt for the number of clouds you needed
in the worst case
so our contexture is at our logo it's
tight and upper bound is doubling tool
and uh maybe this could be proved by
some clever
trick to use a multivariant of the
person theorem
or some ad hoc approach yeah we have
tried some at-home approach but we feel
but maybe we missed some very simple and
clever ad-hoc proof
in the seconds of the problem is to
improve our results on the competitive
side so we call that we only show the
emppk result for that subset Q Star
right because our only for number in Q
star we have matching Urban and
otherwise
so maybe to improve the
the complex result we may first have to
improve in the upper bound and once we
improve upper bound
when we have a very high childhood
directly also improve our complexity
results
so our contract too is about okay
solving a over K in Balance because
division
with two times K minus 1 over K times
uncut this is a conjecture
bound but for both lower bound up front
Okay this problem is in the third
quarter of p k
and contractor three is for the
phenomenon okay the problem get easier
when you get more cost than necessary
and we have a very bold conjecture the
solving Alpha imbalanced Constitution
variance with two uncuts
is already enough to put it in the
intersection of all PPK cards
and the last open problem is to prove
any like PPK harness results
so because now we kind of lack natural
complete problems for class pbk
so for example we conjecture that
solving a over K impedance consist
dividend problem okay with this number
of cards if pdk complete for any
parameter
so it only depends on the denominator
not the numerator
and another motivation for this of the
problem is okay because
we already built some reduction from the
constitute different problem to the
alpha and that's consistent so for
example once you prove the one third
imbalance because it's the very problem
is pk3 complete then you directly get
consists three division is also pp3
complete
and the latter one is a major open
problem in this field
and
advantages of attacking this problem
is that in our problem we only have two
thieves right so
uh it may be easier to design gadgets
with only true label okay with its own
two level we designed gadgets the label
will alternate
and which always be the case in previous
people when showing okay
the PVA completeness for next splitting
and causes Hobby
yeah but if you want to directly design
get it like for example 3 division then
it's trickier because you have three
table
and but maybe it's also not easy because
now you get more cuffs
so what that means is okay like for one
third inverse constitivity
to make a total you have to have four
over three times and cuts okay so now
for each matter function or for each
type of piece you have more than one
class
so maybe you have to design like a
gadget with three mirror function and
four cards and we find this is also
tricky to deal with
so this is our talk and here's the
reference